c'est le retour à l'origine la pièce est
créée un roi le 16 octobre 770 je dis
pas de bêtises peut-être dit une bêtise
ça s'est joué à soir assez glacial
devant le roi et la reine et une
cinquantaine de personnes de la cour
le roi n'a rien dit la fin de la pièce
pendant toute la pièce in à paris n'a
pas dit un mot
il a quitté la salle sans dire un mot
molière était effondré persuadés que non
seulement c'était un bide mecs
équivalait à une disgrâce et le
lendemain il lui a dit c'est la
meilleure qu'hier que nous ayez fait
moins bien c'est un grand soupir de
soulagement
la deuxième je crois c'est passé un peu
mieux que la première c'est ensuite que
le triomphe s'est avéré les aînés les
représentations venant mais la première
de chambord qui sue c'est assez bonne
pensée sac la première de chambord a été
glaciale ça j'aime toujours faire une
enquête sur une enquête assez poussées
sur les conditions historiques le moment
où c'est arrivé le moment que c'est
arrivé dans la carrière de molière le
moment où c'est arrivé dans la situation
de la france à ce moment là les rapports
de molière et de lully à ce moment là je
me suis beaucoup intéressé le rôle de la
musique à versailles ce que pouvait
signifier la création d'une comédie
ballet en ses 170 ça avait un enjeu très
fort parce que
c'est une demande du roi qui le roi qui
a demandé à molière et à lully de
produire une comédie ballet de grande
envergure ou la comédie et la musique
serait profondément liés et molière et
lully ne s'entendait pas vraiment pas
des faux amis
ils étaient rivaux d'ailleurs la toute
première scène de la pièce elle est
assez ironique de ce point de vue là
elle met en scène la rivalité de la
danse et de la musique
tout ça sur la scène du théâtre mais
bourgeois gentilhomme c'est ça c'est la
réunion des arts qui implique aussi le
conflit entre les arts le conflit auprès
du souverain mais aussi la possibilité
d'un théâtre total d'un théâtre qui
accueille embrasse tous les arts de la
même façon que louis xiv voulait les
arts dominé l'europe